come back to CBS this morning there are
three new confirmed cases of corona
virus this morning in the u.s. south of
San Francisco so that brings a total
number of cases in this country to 11
according to health officials there are
more than 17 thousand cases worldwide
the Chinese government says the death
toll there is now risen to 361 and that
is higher than the number of people who
died in China from SARS back in 2003
Raymie innocencio is in Beijing with
more on this story ramie I guess the
question now is what's it like for
Americans living in China yes indeed
good morning Gail the the u.s. ban on
foreign nationals who traveled here to
China is now in effect Beijing is
actually blaming Washington for
overreacting and for spreading fear but
you know more and more countries are
joining the United States in this ban in
Washington is saying that it is
organizing even more evacuation flights
for Americans still stuck in Wuhan
looking on in shock
this man is asked who's died the answers
would my father as men in hazmat suits
tell him it's over
outside several body bags have already
been stacked in a van this widely
circulated video that CBS News can't
independently verify purportedly shows
the situation at a hospital in wuhan
hubei province the epicentre of China's
coronavirus outbreak a grim snapshot of
a city still on historic lockdown
american priscilla Dickey and her
daughter Hermione are stuck in Wuhan
desperately waiting for the next flight
back to the United States the longer
this goes what's your biggest fear Wu
Hans government just finished
construction on one of two new hospitals
for patients built in just 10 days
officials have even deployed drones with
speakers one warns this woman she should
wear a mask
and tells her to go home and wash her
hands despite all efforts the number of
infections keeps rising with nearly
3,000 new cases reported in the past 24
hours over the weekend a Boston student
tested positive he returned from Wuhan
just one day before Logan Airport
started screening for the virus and in
the race for a cure there is some hope
coming out of Thailand doctors there say
that a mix of flu medications and HIV
medications is showing quote vast
improvement for some patients there over
48 hours so here's hoping
Anthony rush for a vaccine Ramey
Inocencio in Beijing thank you very much
you